Andrés forero Muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en France 24 en español
quisiera comenzar preguntándote si crees
que esta medida legitima de alguna
manera los actos de todo tipo de
violencias contra las personas lgbt como
ya ocurrió por ejemplo en 2013 cuando
hubo una suerte de ola de crímenes de
odio en Rusia
Hola buenas tardes y gracias por tenerme
y a tu pregunta sin duda alguna esta ley
es completamente la manera en la cual el
gobierno ruso le está diciendo a las
personas de Rusia que no pueden existir
que las personas lgbt no podemos existir
públicamente Incluso en el año pasado
con esta ley que se mencionaba antes la
del 2013 que solamente prohibía la
propaganda lgbt a menores ha habido
múltiples arrestos incluso varios
activistas han estado tras las rejas han
estado amenazadas durante muchísimo
tiempo e incluso nada más un grupo
adolescentes el año pasado en San
Petersburgo que tiraba una foto inocente
con su bandera arcoiris fue detenido por
la policía Entonces estamos hablando de
que justamente es un paso más que nos
sorprende no pero es muy grave que está
dando el gobierno ruso hacia el
financiamiento de las personas lgbt en
la sociedad como tal Andrés Sí con esta
ley crees que se va a perpetuar aún más
en Rusia a la visión de que la
homosexualidad nocivo Hablamos de una
perspectiva que por supuesto atrasa años
no recordemos que hace ya más de tres
décadas que la Organización Mundial de
la Salud dejó de calificar a la
homosexualidad como una enfermedad
sin duda alguna así la MS haya hecho lo
que haya hecho y así tantas
organizaciones activistas en Rusia
justamente hayan trabajado por ese tema
el gobierno Sigue pensando que esto es
un tema de pues de lo cual no se habla
es un tema de los valores tradicionales
que Pues en realidad es es un discurso
que vemos en otros lugares del mundo que
buscan callar los derechos lgbt
recordemos que este año comenzando el
gobierno ruso cerró la organización
activista lgbt más grande y antigua del
país la federación rusa lgbt y Pues
básicamente con esto al no permitir que
existan organizaciones sociales que
hayan que hagan activismo y que
acompañen a las personas lgbt el
gobierno ruso está dejando las personas
lgbt sin ningún tipo de acompañamiento y
sin ningún tipo de presencia entonces
Esta es una ley pero luego vendrán otras
y otras y otras y bueno incluso algo que
debemos rescatar es que esta ley
impidió se impidió que las personas que
hicieran propaganda lgbt
recibirán penas criminales Por así
decirlo y fueran llevadas a la cárcel
seguramente van a tener multas pero pues
depósitos algo ya bastante grave en un
país que tiene tanta violencia policial
hacia las personas Andrés nos queda poco
tiempo pero no quiero dejar de
realizarte Una última pregunta que es
que Rusia está marcando esto en una
suerte de contienda verdad hace
referencia a los valores promovidos por
occidente cree que otro objetivo además
de ampliar este control y la represión
no al colectivo sería presentar a Rusia
como garante de los valores
tradicionales
sin duda alguna este discurso sobre los
valores tradicionales que busca
preservar una forma tradicional de
familia por supuesto es justamente el
que se ha propagado en toda Rusia y el
que también se está propagando en otros
países vecinos recordemos que Hungría
Polonia y recientemente Rumanía también
tuvieron intenciones de crear leyes
parecidas entonces lo que hace esto es
crear una suerte de efecto dominó que
empieza a expandir este pensamiento en
otros lugares y al ser las
organizaciones activistas organizaciones
que están en la posición vulnerable
frente al gobierno autoritario de Putin
pues sin duda alguna esto es parte por
supuesto de recomienda mucho más grande
que pone en riesgo a miles de personas l